on the site of what was once a hatab
home
where 10 members of one family were
killed in an israeli airstrike
artists want to ensure they are not
forgotten
they are painting about life inside
these walls before they were reduced to
rubble
we came today in an initiative called
painting over the rubble
to draw and paint over the homes we want
to deliver a message that no matter what
happens in gaza
and no matter what they do we shall
remain patient and resistant and we
shall have hope for tomorrow
other artists from the gaza strip have
held an exhibition
called we were repainted this
humanitarian scene
sheds light on the fear mixed with
feelings of longing
for those who were killed in the israeli
bombardment
artists are as vulnerable to israeli
attacks
as the refugees in the camps and not all
their work survives
we were preparing for a art exhibition
in ramadan and it was supposed to be
after eid
but then the war happened and our art
atelier was badly destroyed and all our
paintings were destroyed too
this sculpture is one of the art
collections called dignities
that i worked on after the war of 2014
because these 11 days of war brought
back all the sorrows and tragedies that
we lived before
to deliver a message to the world that
we will continue with our art
and with our lives despite all the
tragedies we go through
other sculptures and paintings of people
young and old
embody the feeling of hope dreams as
well
as reality palestinian artists have
chosen to convey messages of peace to
the world
and to remember those who were killed in
the israeli attacks
you may see it al jazeera gaza